foreign
we don't know who had been putting in
the provisions and Records to say that a
service member was arrested when they
were not arrested that has got to be
stopped we can't allow people to put
false allegations into records as if
they're facts people should be better
trained to avoid that and they should be
investigated for falsifying military
records
foreign
[Music]
they came under scrutiny for not
properly policing the program so that
they created this task force Raptor and
went after everybody that got paid under
the program that provision that titling
as having been investigated for fraud
even though there was no evidence of
fraud has ruined thousands of careers of
people who did recruit people there was
some of fraud no question but not to the
extent of what the Army has done to
people that they did their job they
recruited people they got paid it all
that worked
the irony in this is that the people
that volunteered to protect our nation
are the people whose fundamental rights
and due process rights are being taken
away from the real bad part is that the
military didn't even do the courtesy of
telling them for about eight years these
people have been going through and just
thinking they they're not they don't
have any luck they're not getting you
know the right jobs and and you know
they must not have gotten selected for
promotion because of you know maybe they
rub somebody the wrong way and in
reality
they were being sabotaged by Army CID we
in the uh justice for warriors caucus
have been trying to get an amendment to
the National Defense authorization act
we were wanting to amend the titling
system and Matt Gates when I showed him
the situation he said oh my gosh this is
so unfair destroying lives so he had put
forward an amendment to the ndaa this
past year but it didn't get enough votes
what we've run into in Congress
is people
that are a little uneasy
about fixing a situation they're afraid
well gee if we do that could it open up
allegations that we're trying to cover
for somebody's fraud all it takes is
somebody vindictive to in Congress to
say something about oh you're you're
just trying to cover up for criminals
and then people back off and they're
afraid to touch it but we've got to have
people of Courage enough and I think we
will next year we're winning over
converts to help our military members
who have been so unjustly created
treated and we're hoping that that will
happen next year even though it did not
this year CPAC is working with members
of the Guard who have been impacted by
this uh whole program in this whole mess
and we're connecting them to their
legislators and then we're working with
their Council
to one draft language that will require
the Pentagon to notify everyone who's
received a title so that everyone's at
least aware there's a problem
our view is that if there hasn't been a
criminal prosecution those titles
shouldn't exist we've been talking to
members of the armed services in the
house and the Congressional Judiciary
committees who are sensitive to these
issues
given our role we're really focusing on
on Republican offices with the
expectation that we're going to have
both chambers of Congress after November
right at the beginning of Congress let's
have a hearing on this issue a public
hearing where people can testify as to
the impact of this
uh malfeasance
and we hope to have that hearing in
January or February
we're going to be very aggressive in
this that you know we've got warfighters
and Veterans who
um every day they are suffering Economic
Consequences emotional consequences this
is a righteous fight one of the things
that I would like to see is
people talk to their members of Congress
in the senate about unfairness that's
happening to our military members and
tell them to talk to those of us that
have been in the Congressional Justice
for warriors caucus about the massive
amount of Injustice that we've seen that
we're finding in the military
because we have got to have a strong
America as I've said since I was in the
Army any
country that does not honor those that
have honored it with their service in
the military won't stay a free country
very long
[Music]